okay what is whites main idea in this
position guys let's say white is trying
to win thank you let's say white is
trying to win what's the main idea by
the way this is on a very locked up pawn
structure right it's very unusual pawn
structure because look it's obviously
many pieces have been traded but there's
so many pawns to left on the board and
they're locked up and they're not really
any open lines right so it's an unusual
position for sure but imagine something
like this happen it can happen
um you know let's say what is white is
going to try to do to try to win this
game it's actually you know what fine if
we put that pawn here white just has an
extra pawn that makes sense that's fine
okay what is white going to try to do to
win AJ how
how you get rid of the bishop
all right guys white I was going to try
to break through you know the queen of
the night are not here by accident the
only way to try to sort of open up the
position is to play b6 right that's why
the night it has has gone to a four so
if he plays b6 he's opening up a way in
for his queen
for example the queen can come in if the
Queen comes in you know he starts making
different threats on white can win the
game right so imagine something like
that obviously only white can win this
position right this bishop really cannot
do anything it's kind of like a big pawn
does it have anything to attack all
these pawns are in different Square from
him
so this this position I saw in a book
called the most amazing chess moves of
all time and black has an idea that he
could just play here oh isn't that
surprising what's the point of this move
guys it looks like it has a very big
problem doesn't it
Sam how is that going to break wise
defensive line yeah but on to down a
queen for a bish of their weight but
you're giving up a night a queen for a
night in itself that's all almost always
a losing decision right and what you're
telling me is you're giving up the queen
for the night and then you're going to
try to attack me with what with your
bishop against my queen right but you're
going to play here but that only loses
another pawn now white wins really
easily if you give me that pawn like now
my queen is going to come in here I'm
going to start eating all your pawns
your Bishop is helpless you know Queen
is worth something guys right I mean in
almost all positions an advantage like
this is absolutely winning but why would
black voluntarily put their queen on
that square no one was forcing them so
they must have some idea what is the
idea behind the move Queen to b6 Isabel
they are going for a draw because
they're worse to start with right
they're trying to defend but what are
they going to make a draw based on I
mean how can giving up your queen for a
night ever lead to a draw why would that
be a good idea Charlie
right well this that's that's on the
right track charlie it's pretty much it
of course you know white is going to
take the Queen right because otherwise
we've also when we play Queen b6 we are
stopping White's main idea of advancing
their pawn right so that's the main
point - Queen b6 but normally we
wouldn't be able to make that move
because we lose our queen however let's
talk about the resulting position
remember I told you this is an unusual
pawn position pawn structure is very
locked it's you know no open lines
how does white make progress here with
his extra Queen like what's the plan I'm
just going to sit around with my king I
don't touch my pawn definitely not
giving up any pawn not moving my bishop
anywhere I'm just gonna you know sit
here and here what is White's plan to
win you know maybe I can you know yeah
I'll stay around here how is why I can
try to win this guy's can they break
through anywhere with the Queen can they
show the power of the Queen and the
answer is no well if you don't take then
you're not playing b6 and then that your
main idea was gone then then you'll have
to make some other move and you also
don't really have anywhere to break
through
so I Queen b6 was trying to stop your
main breakthrough idea um so the problem
is the Queen just you know you're not
going to sacrifice your queen for a pawn
right that's not going to help you
that's only going to lose the game for
you and the Queen cannot invade cannot
kind of get past this if you can put the
Queen anywhere here it usually wins
because then the Queen will overpower
the King and start winning pawns right
but the problem is the Queen cannot get
outside of the pawn chain so this is let
me tell you guys this is very unusual
this is why this example made it into
the most amazing chess moves of all time
because you don't normally give up your
queen for night and then make a draw
right um
and here's the thing guys this is a
special kind of position Black has
something called a fortress have you
heard that ever and chest you know we
hear that in chess a lot a fortress is
something that you can't can you can't
do what with you can't break through you
can't break through you can't break down
so black makes a draw based on the
fortress idea that his position is
impregnable
you just can't enter it anywhere except
one thing black has to lose this okay
I'm going to give you an example so a
tough question but I think you guys can
figure it out let's say my king like
it's a little bit careless and instead
of moving his King on this part of the
board he moves it over here let's say
you can move it here white now has at
least an idea to win white has an idea
now who can think of it what what did it
change where I moved my king and what
kind of idea to give white that's why
it's important just to have a fantasy
you know to have a dream of what you can
try to accomplish here you need to
imagine where you're winning chances can
come from
Charlie queen bee for
so I'm going to let's say take it let's
say I take it see five you're doing a
pawn break oh that's very clever very
good so this is a breakthrough with the
pawns and where white is the one now who
sacrifices his material advantage and
these pawns overpower these defenders
and the bishop and the King are helpless
to do anything about it
because the pawn is threatening to just
go here become a queen again where if
this pawn takes then unfortunately for
black no one can stop the D pawn on time
I move the King just far away enough for
you to be able to make that idea work
Charlie
if the King had been just one square
closer black could be in time to stop
the pawn and win the game but the King
is so far that he is not able to get
into the square in time with that he
needs to be in and the bishop as you see
cannot jump here cannot take the place
of its own pawn and no one is stopping
this pawn from promoting did we see that
very good idea Charlie so white has an
idea of sacrificing material back in
order to break down the fortress and um
and get a passed pawn the other idea
that I had for you um was you could go
here and sacrifice your queen for this
pawn because that's the same idea that
you have with the move Queen before if I
ignore you like if I play let's say here
you have to make the same idea work you
have to sacrifice your queen for this
pawn in order to get your b-pawn moving
and black cannot stop the b-pawn from
promoting to another Queen do we see
that what do you think
no you can't that's a good question
that's a good point you're making but in
fact you cannot sacrifice your queen for
this pawn because black is going to
capture back which way there are two
ways one of them loses one of the wins
or at least if not wins it's close to or
at least black doesn't lose like might
not be able to win because of the
fortress still on the board but which
way should black can recapture here guys
think about it
Isabel with the D pawn because there
Kate because then the past pawn that
white has is this pawn and the king is
close enough to stop it right he's right
there so that if tries to promote the
king takes it right down the other way
the king is forced if you capture with
the b-pawn then um then the king is too
far from the b-pawn it becomes a queen
so it actually does make a big
difference which pawn you take in this
position c5 or a5 right it's always
never too late to make a mistake but if
you take this way you win the game
because you get a passed pawns remember
what I said what if well what Philidor
said was the past pawns
oh no pawns of the soul of chess
especially when they become past pawns
and you give up you can even give up
your Queen because for this one little
pawn to get a free path up the board to
the b8 square so why did I give you this
example guys it's obviously very unusual
but the idea was when we were talking
about different the value of material on
the board right is that even though yes
Queen is worth nine rooks are worth five
bishops and Knights are worth three it's
still in every particular position it's
still kind of a relative thing you know
it's not completely fixed in this
position you know even though white has
a coin
Black has a bishop the result is a draw
right so the actual strength of the
material you have depends on every
position you guys understand that
you